the hearing will come to order
officially this was a hearing about the
fbi's mishandling of the investigation
into the sexual abuse of women and girls
treated by former olympics team doctor
larry nassar but as survivors testified
it was clear their goal was to go much
further to be clear i blame larry nassar
and i also blame
an entire system
that enabled and
perpetrated his abuse
nasa has been sentenced up to 235 years
in prison but a department of justice
report found the fbi had been alerted to
his abuse in 2015 and didn't take the
allegations seriously it didn't even
alert local authorities which meant nasa
continued molesting athletes when the
allegations were finally investigated
officials minimized the athlete's
suffering i told them i walked the halls
of tokyo hotel at 2 am at only 15 years
old i began crying at the memory over
the phone and there was just dead
silence
i was so shocked at the age of silence
and disregard for my trauma after that
minute of silence he asked
is that all
once nasa's behavior was exposed agents
lied to the doj inquiry into what had
gone so wrong they haven't been
prosecuted for their conduct
controversially the department of
justice refused to testify about why
that was the case
for the survivors of the abuse this was
just the latest example of a broken
system not just at the fbi and the
department of justice but also at usa
gymnastics and the u.s olympic and
paralympic committees whom they said did
everything they could to cover up the
abuse
beyond prosecuting those involved in the
cover-up the survivors want a full
independent investigation nothing should
be off limits it should go back decades
and that has not been done and it's been
something that we've been asking for
for years and years and so i personally
would like to see
all three organizations completely
investigated and
the scope of it matters because until we
know all the facts it's just guesswork
also speaking at the hearing the current
director of the fbi he wasn't in charge
during the investigation into nasa i'm
sorry for what you and your families
have been through if allegations raised
by well-known world-class athletes are
not taken seriously by the fbi
what hope do other
victims of sexual assault have
it was clear from their testimony that
these four olympians feel that the
official response to their abuse has not
been sufficient shia britancy al jazeera
capitol hill